[Music]
I'd like to talk about my dad my dad has
Alzheimer's disease he started showing
the symptoms about 12 years ago and he
was officially diagnosed in 2005 now
he's really pretty sick he needs help
eating he needs help getting dressed he
doesn't really know where he is or when
it is and it's been really really hard
my dad was my hero and my mentor for
most of my life and I've spent the last
decade watching him disappear my dad's
not alone there's about 35 million
people globally living with some kind of
dementia and by 2030
they're expecting that to double to 70
million that's a lot of people dementia
scares us the confused faces and shaky
hands of people who have dementia the
big numbers of people who get it they
frighten us and because of that fear we
tend to do one of two things we go into
the Nile it's not me it has nothing to
do with me it's never gonna happen to me
or we decide that we're gonna prevent
dementia and it will never happen to us
because we are going to do everything
right and it won't come and get us I'm
looking for a third way I'm preparing to
get Alzheimer's disease prevention is
good and I'm doing the things that you
can do to prevent Alzheimer's I'm eating
right I'm exercising every day I'm
keeping my mind active that's what the
research says you should do but the
research also shows that there's nothing
that will 100% protect you if the
monster wants you the monster is going
to get you that's what happened with my
dad my dad was a bilingual college
professor his hobbies were chess bridge
and writing op-eds
he got dementia anyway if the monster
wants to you
the monster is gonna get you especially
if you're me because Alzheimer's tends
to run in families
so I'm preparing to get Alzheimer's
disease based on what I've learned from
taking care of my father and researching
what it's like to live with dementia I'm
focusing on three things in my
preparation I'm changing what I do for
fun I'm working to build my physical
strength and this is the hard one I'm
trying to become a better person let's
start with the hobbies when you get
dementia it gets harder and harder to
enjoy yourself you can't sit and have
long talks with your old friends because
you don't know who they are it's
confusing to watch television and often
very frightening and reading is just
about impossible when you care for
someone with dementia and you get
training they train you to engage them
in activities that are familiar hands-on
open-ended with my dad that turned out
to be letting him fill out forms he was
a college professor at a state school
he knows what paperwork looks like he'll
find his name on every line he'll check
all the boxes he'll put numbers in where
he thinks there should be numbers but it
got me thinking what would my caregivers
do with me I'm my father's daughter I
read I write I think about global health
a lot would they give me academic
journals so I could scribble on the
margins would they give me a charts and
graphs that I could color so I've been
trying to learn to do things that are
hands-on I've always liked to draw so
I'm doing it more even though I'm really
very bad at it I am learning some basic
origami I can make a really great box
and I'm teaching myself to knit which so
far I can knit a blob but you know it
doesn't matter if it's if I'm actually
good at it what matters is that my hands
know how to do it because the more
things that are familiar the more things
my hands know how to do the more things
that I can be happy and busy doing when
my brains not running the show anymore
they say that people who are engaged in
activities are happier easier for their
caregivers to look after it may even
slow the progress of the disease that
all seems like when to me I want to be
as happy as I can for as long as I can a
lot of people don't know that
Alzheimer's actually has physical
symptoms as well as cognitive symptoms
you lose your sense of balance you get
muscle tremors and that tends to lead
people to being less and less mobile
they get scared to walk around they get
scared to move so I'm doing activities
that will build my sense of balance I'm
doing yoga and Tai Chi to improve my
balance so that when I start to lose it
I'll still be able to be mobile I'm
doing weight-bearing exercise so that I
have the muscle strength so that when I
start to wither I have more time that I
can still move around finally the third
thing I'm trying to become a better
person my dad was kind and loving before
he had Alzheimer's and he's kind of
loving now I've seen him lose his
intellect his sense of humor his
language skills but I've also seen this
he loves me he loves my sons he loves my
brother and my mom and his caregivers
and that love makes us want to be around
him even now even when it's so hard when
you take away everything that he ever
learned in this world his naked heart
still shines I was never as kind as my
dad and I was never as loving and what I
need now is to learn to be like that I
need a heart so pure that if it's
stripped bare by dementia it will
survive I don't want to get Alzheimer's
disease what I want is a cure in the
next 20 years soon enough to protect me
but if it comes from me I'm gonna be
ready thank you
[Applause]